WE'RE GONNA START TODAY'S ROBIN
TAX COMMITTEE HEARING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL TO THE COMEDIAN.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WE HAVE THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
BUT WE ARE GOING TO START WITH
ITEM NUMBER NINE.
AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES AB ONE THIRD AB
THIRTY ONE FIFTY TWO WOULD GIVE.
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION FOR
RENTAL HOUSING UNITS DESIGNED
FOR MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE SO CALLED
MISSING MIDDLE AYE IN HIGH COST
PARTS
STATE.
I THINK MANY OF YOU ARE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT STATE HOUSING
CRISIS THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW
AND THIS IS A BILL TO ADDRESS
THE PLIGHT OF MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE SO CALLED
MISSING MIDDLE. POOR IN A TOUGH
SPOT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOUSEHOLDS
WHO ARE OF MODERN INCOME UNABLE
TO AFFORD MARKET RATE HOUSING
BUT WHO EARN TOO MUCH TO QUALIFY
FOR SUBSIDIZED. LOW INCOME
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AMONG OTHERS THE MISSING MIDDLE
INCLUDES TEACHERS FIREFIGHTERS
AND EMERGENCY RESPONDERS
HEALTHCARE CHILDCARE OR RETAIL
WORKERS WHO ARE ALL CRITICAL TO
OUR COMMUNITIES THERE OFTEN
COMMUNITY EXHAUSTING HOURS IN
GRIDLOCK TRAFFIC EVERY WEEK.
FROM THE LOWER COST AREAS TO
HIGH COST JOBCENTRE.
THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE A
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION TO
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS TO BUILD
RENTAL HOUSING FOR MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING. DEFINED AS THOSE
MAKING BETWEEN EIGHTY AND A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY PERCENT AM I.
THE SAVINGS FROM THE PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION TO NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS WOULD BE USED TO
REDUCE RENTS TO MODERATE INCOME
LEVELS. DEVELOPERS WOULD ONLY BE
ABLE TO CHARGE TENANTS THIRTY
PERCENT OF THEIR HOUSEHOLD
INCOME FOR RENT.
AND IN ADDITION THE RATE OF RED
WOULD BE AT LEAST TEN PERCENT
BELOW THE FAIR MARKET RENT. AS
DETERMINED BY HIDE AND A
RENTS ARE ALREADY LOW BECAUSE
THEIR SET EVERY FIVE YEARS AND
DO NOT REFLECT CURRENT MARKET
CONDITIONS.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT TAKE AWAY
RESOURCES FROM LOWER INCOME
UNITS THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
RECEIVE FEDERAL AND STATE
FUNDING.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE ARE AND THE CHAIR FOR
SUGGESTING A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL.
AT THIS TIME ARE UNPREPARED TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD LIMIT
THE EXEMPTION TO NEW MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
ALSO THE EXEMPTION THAT WOULD BE
LIMITING TO MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS A WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE A MINIMUM NUMBER OF
UNITS.
I AND I AM ALSO PREPARED TO
ACCEPT AN AMENDMENT THAT WOULD
NOT ALLOW THE LIMITED
PARTNERSHIP TO ENTER INTO WHAT
IS KNOWN AS QUOTE. OTHER LEGAL
DOCUMENTS TO SELF IMPOSED WENT
OCCUPANCY RESTRICTIONS.
RATHER THAN MARRYING THE
LANGUAGE IN THE EXEMPTION FOR
LOW INCOME UNITS. ONE ALSO TAKE
A MOMENT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS AND I KNOW
NOW THAT THERE IS INTEREST AND
THINKING ABOUT HOW. THIS BILL
MIGHT BE SUNSET ED IN THE LONG
HAUL SO THAT THERE IS A LONG
TERM LIMITATION ON THE VALUE OF
THE EXEMPTION OVER TIME.
WE JUST HAD A CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT AN HOUR AGO A I'M HAPPY
TO WORK ON THIS I'M VERY OPEN TO
THIS.
HOPEFULLY HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME TO FIGURE OUT THE DETAILS
BUT I DO THINK THAT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR NEW POLICY.
MOVING FORWARD AGAIN TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE. AND DEALT WITH
THAT.
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR OUR
SUPPORTERS AND SPONSORS ARE
STARTING FIRST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
AND MARINA WHITE.
THINK YEAR OLD GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARINO
WENT CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM WE ARE IN A NON
PARTISAN ADVOCATE FOR THE
PRODUCTION PRESERVATION OF LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSING.
REPRESENTING THE BUILDING
DEVELOPMENT FINANCE ON PUBLIC
SECTORS UNITED IN THEIR GOAL
THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA HAVE A
SAFE AFFORDABLE PLACE TO CALL
HOME. LAST YEAR I LEGISLATURE
STEPPED UP TO INVEST IN THE
TOOLS IN FUNDING. TO START
ADDRESSING OUR HOUSING CRISIS
BUT THERE'S SO MUCH WORK AHEAD
TO KEEP.
STRUGGLING CALIFORNIANS AND
AFFORDABLE HOMES AS MANY OF YOU
NOTED OVER THE PAST YEAR THE
HOUSING CRISIS IS SO SEVERE THAT
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES. ON THE
WORKING PROFESSIONALS THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU MENTIONED A
MOMENT AGO ARE STRUGGLING TO
AFFORD HOUSING AND AB THIRTY ONE
FIFTY TWO IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL
TO INCENTIVIZE THE PRODUCTION OF
NEW RENTAL HOUSING UNITS. IN
HIGH COST AREAS SO THAT OUR
SEATS VITAL MISSING METAL CAN
AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY WORK.
EXISTING PROPERTY ALREADY ALLOWS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
TO QUALIFY FOR WELFARE EXEMPTION
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE
AFFORDABILITY OF HOUSING UNITS
OCCUPIED FOR A LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
AND AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY TO
CREATE A SIMILAR EXEMPTION FOR
RENTAL HOUSING UNITS THAT
RESTRICT RENTS A THIRTY PERCENT
OF MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THAT IS HOUSEHOLDS WITH INCOMES
BETWEEN EIGHTY AND HUNDRED
TWENTY PERCENT OF THE AREA
MEDIAN TIME SO LONG AS THOSE
UNITS ARE IN THE HIGH COST
COUNTIES AND THE RENTS ARE IS
STILL AT LEAST TEN PERCENT
BELOW.
MARKET RATES IN THE GOAL HERE IS
TO ENSURE THAT ANY PROPERTY TAX
REDUCTION IS BEING USED TO
MAINTAIN THE AFFORDABILITY OF
THOSE UNITS.
WITHOUT THIS TOOL TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING UNITS TO BE PRODUCED AT
THE MARKET AND I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR BURKE AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AMY CHAN AND
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE SAN
FRANCISCO MAYOR'S OFFICE OF
HOUSING. AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
OFFICE AND WE WANT EXPRESSED
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTY
ONE FIFTY TWO AND THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE. AND THERE'S A
GREAT NEED FOR MODERATE MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES I AM TO STAY IN
CITIES LIKE SAN FRANCISCO. THEY
MAKE UP A VERY DIVERSE SET OF
OUR WORK FORCE AND AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS MENTIONED
THEY ARE TEACHERS. ARE SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE FIREFIGHTERS AND YET
HIGH COST CITIES ARE NOT MEETING
THE NEED TO HOUSE MODERATE
INCOME FAMILIES BETWEEN EIGHTY
TO HUNDRED TWENTY PERCENT OF ON
THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME. IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
THE MARKET IS SERVING REALLY
HOUSEHOLDS AND A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PERCENT OF AND MY AND
ABOVE. WHAT THAT MEANS IN TERMS
OF RENTS ARE AN AVERAGE TWO
BEDROOM HAS BEEN AS HIGH AS
FORTY TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH? WEARS A FAMILY OF THREE
MAKING EIGHTY PERCENT OF AM I
CAN ONLY AFFORD TO PAY TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTY FIVE
DOLLARS A MONTH. OR FAMILY OF
THREE MAKING HUNDRED AND TWENTY
PERCENT OF AM I CAN ONLY AFFORD
TO PAY THIRTY ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH. THAT LEAVES A
HUGE AFFORDABLE AFFORDABILITY
CAP FOR OUR MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES ON AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SEEING OVER THE LAST FEW DECADES
A STEADY DECLINE AND MODERATE
INCOME.
HOUSEHOLDS ON LEAVING THE CITY
AND WHAT WE'RE ALSO SEEING IS
TEACHERS LEAVING OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT AT AN ATTRITION
.
THE SAN FRANCISCO IS ACTUALLY
INVESTED.
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
MODERATE INCOME PRODUCTION
THROUGH A HOUSING ON HOUSING
BOND THAT WE PASSED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. BUT THESE FUNDS ARE
LIMITED AND I'M WOULD ONLY
GENERATE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED UNITS
TOTAL. AND WHICH IS WELL BELOW
THE FIVE THOUSAND UNITS WE NEED
TO HOUSE MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES.
ACCORDING TO OUR REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
SO WE ARE IN DIRE NEED OF MORE
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THAT
MISSING MS THIS MISSING METAL.
AND EXPANDING THE WELFARE TAX
EXEMPTION TO SERVE THESE
HOUSEHOLDS UP TO ONE TWENTY
PERCENT EVERY OF AIR IN MEDIAN
INCOME WOULD BE A VERY EFFECTIVE
TOOL FOR US.
AND THIS EXEMPTION WANTED
INCENTIVIZE GREATER PRODUCTION A
MODERATE AND MIDDLE INCOME UNITS
BY REDUCING THE OPERATING COSTS
FOR THESE UNITS AND IN TURN
ALLOWING OUR HOUSING DEVELOPERS
TO LEVERAGE MORE REVENUE IS
SMALL. AND GIVEN
THAT THE EXEMPTION IS ONLY
LIMITED TO CERTAIN ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES AND ONLY APPLY TO UNITS
IN HIGH COST CITIES WHERE THE
RENTS AT EIGHTY TO HUNDRED
TWENTY PERCENT OF AND MY. AND
SHOWN TO BE BELOW THE FAIR
MARKET RENT.
IN COMPARISON WE JUST SEE A
TREMENDOUS.
PUBLIC BENEFIT IN CREATING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR A
MODERATE AND MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES AND SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THINKING.
OTHERS WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL AIM WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. A BILL COSPONSORED
STRONG SUPPORT.
TIFFANY FAN HAVE A BRIDGE
HOUSING IT'S PART.
REBECCA MARCUS AND.
IN SUPPORT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL.
SO.
THIS MY FIRST TIME ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO TELL
EVERYONE THAT I AM. AN AVOWED
EXPERTS.
ON REVENUE AND TAXATION.
LET ME PRESENT MY CREDENTIALS.
AS AN ELEVEN YEAR OLD. IN THE
BACKWOODS OF MISSOURI.
OUR I WAS IN CHARGE OF. BEING A
P. WE'D LOOK OUT ON ONE OF THE
TRAILS LEADING
I PAID HEAVY TAXES BY WHOLE
LIFE.
AND.
HAVE NEVER. EVER FAILED. A ARE
COMPLETE FORENSIC.
AUDIT.
SO.
THOSE ARE MY CREDENTIALS I
SUPPORT THIS BILL I DIDN'T
FORGET ABOUT THROUGH FOR.
ANOTHER TAX
EXPERTS OR BUT.
I LIVE IN THE VERY HIGH BECAUSE
OF THE. OF THE AREA SO I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE HOPE
THIS BILL TO HELP OUT WITH. A
LOT OF WORKING POOR SUE YOU MY
DISTRICT. I WILL LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION THAT ALSO WILL
ASTRONOMICAL I'M SURE WE MIGHT
HAVE A QUORUM BUT I'D LIKE TO.
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR BURKE. AND ALL SECOND THE
MOTION.
WHEN THAT WHEN WE HAVE A CORE
QUORUM.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY FIRST OF
ALL THANK YOU FOR TAKING OUT
SOME OF THE CHAIRS AMENDMENTS IN
AGREEING TO LOOK AT THE REST.
THAT HAS SET CONVINCED ME THAT
THAT THE BILL REALLY NEEDS TO GO
ON IT'S FOR VERY GOOD COST THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
I VERY MUCH WANT TO THANK OUR.
THE COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION
INCLUDING.
ITS NEWEST MEMBER AND.
AND AND THOSE OF YOU WHO
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS WERE AND. THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS RIGHT NOW
THIS IS HOUSING THAT IS NOT
BEING BUILT SO THERE ARE NO
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES TO BE
COLLECTED. BUT IF WE ARE ABLE TO
GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF AN
EXEMPTION.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
HOUSING THAT COULD BE CREATED TO
ADDRESS A VERY SIGNIFICANT.
SHORTAGE THAT WE HAVE NOW
FACING OUR MIDDLE CLASS AND ARE
WORKING FAMILIES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I DO THINK THAT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE ASKED OF US
BY THE COMMITTEE WERE WERE
REASONABLE. AYE AND.
AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHT GOING INTO IT I KNOW FOR
A FEW THEM WE NEED A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME TO. MAKE SURE THAT.
IF WE TAKE THEM PROJECTS WILL
PENCIL OUT AND WE WILL HAVE THE
DESIRED IMPACT BUT ALSO DO YOU
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMITTEE. WANTS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE ARE SOME LIMITATIONS UP SO
THAT WE ARE IN SENDING THIS BUT
NOT OVERLY INSULTING THAT SO WE
WANT TO CREATE THE RIGHT
BALANCE.
UP WITH THAT.
AGAIN THANK YOU IN THE CHAIR OF
FRAWLEY WORKING RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT.
SO JUST FOR CLARIFICATION YOU
TAKING A MEMBER NUMBER FOR THE
MODIFY RAN ELIGIBILITY TO BOTH
RENT RENT SAID AND AFFORDABLE
LEVEL AND AFFORDABLE RENTS MUST
BE AT LEAST TEN PERCENT BELOW
FAIR MARKET VALUE DO SO AS WE
DISCUSSED.
WE HAD NOT HAD A CHANCE TO RUN
WHAT THE NUMBER IS BUT WE HAVE.
IT WE'D WE RECEIVE I WAS
BRIEFED ON THE MINUTES OVER THE
WEEKEND AND WE'VE JUST STARTED
THIS MORNING TO SAY I WILL POINT
WITH THIS PENCIL OUT I'M WILLING
TO LOWER THAT. IS ONE MAKE SURE
NOT LOWERING. WHEN IT SAYS LIMIT
IT TO A LARGE AMOUNT WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT LARGE AMOUNT IS
SO YES I'M WILLING TO SUPPORT
THERE IS A LARGE AMOUNT BUT WHAT
THAT NUMBER IS WERE STILL
TRAFFIC ROUTE. I AND I DO I
WANTED TO YOU I DO APPRECIATE
OUR CONVERSATION WE DIDN'T HAVE
YOU KNOW MY CONCERN IS THE TEN
PERCENT BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU NEED TO. I UNDERSTAND THE
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY OF THESE BUILDERS
AND SO I KNOW YOU'RE WAITING FOR
SOME REPORTS BACK ON WHAT. THAT
WILL LOOK LIKE SO WITH WITH THAT
WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL VOTE.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU TO THE CLINIC.
NEXT UP IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY TWO MISTER
GALLAGHER.
I THINK MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
.
FOR A START LIKE PUT OUT I ALSO
AM AN EXPERT ON REVENUE AND TAX.
I JUST PAID MY TAXES.
THIS YEAR.
I'M A REVENUE SO.
THERE'S MY COULD AT THOSE ARE MY
CREDENTIALS AS WELL.
THEY WAYS.
I APPRECIATED THE.
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS STORY THERE
THOSE GOOD THOSE VERY.
.
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY TWO TRIES
TO ADDRESS A PROBLEM THAT WE
SAW.
DURING THE WILDFIRE AS SEASON
HERE IN IN IN THIS SUCH ISSUE
IS.
IS RIGHT NOW IN THE CURRENT LAW
WHEN YOU.
.
ASK FOR A DIFFERENT TAXES.
YOU YOU HAVE TO DO SO BASICALLY.
MAKING THE CLAIM THAT YOUR
DAMAGE A DURING A NATIONAL
DISASTER WAS AT LEAST TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE.
AND IN SOME CASES A LOT OF
PEOPLE MIGHT NOT KNOW THE EXACT
EXTENT OF WHAT THEIR DAMAGES AND
SO THEY GET PUT INTO A PLACE
WHERE.
AND IF AND IF YOU MAKE A BAD
FAITH CLAIM FOR THIS DEFERRAL
YOU CAN YOU COULD FACE
PENALTIES.
SO PUTS A LOT OF TAXPAYERS IN
THE SITUATION WHERE. THEY MAY
NOT MAKE THAT CLAIM.
OUT OF FEAR THAT THEY COULD BE
CONSIDERED NOT GOOD FAITH.
AND SO.
A WEEK OR OR THEY JUST DON'T
APPLY AT ALL.
AND WOULD RATHER HAVE PEOPLE
APPLYING FOR THESE ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY'VE BEEN FACE OF THE
DEVASTATING DISASTER LIKE
WILDFIRE. HAS TO AB THREE THIRTY
ONE TWENTY TO ENSURE IS THAT
INDIVIDUALS IMPACTED BY NATURAL
DISASTERS.
LIKE THE RECENT WILDFIRES ARE
PUT IN THAT POSITION
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL CLARIFIES
THAT PAYMENT OF PROPERTY TAXES
CAN BE DEFERRED. UNTIL THE
ASSESSOR HAS DETERMINED A
PROPERTY IS NOT ELIGIBLE SO IF
ONCE THE ASSESSOR DETERMINES NO
THERE'S LESS THAN TEN THOUSAND
OR ITS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR SOME
OTHER REASON.
.
THEN THERE WERE THEY WOULD GIVE
NOTICE TO THE TAXPAYER. AND PER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHICH WE ARE
TAKING.
FROM THE DATE OF THAT MAILING.
ON THE.
NOTICE THAT THE TAXPAYER WOULD
HAVE THIRTY DAYS TO.
THEN PAY THEIR TAXES. SO IT JUST
TRIES TO YOU KNOW CLARIFY AN
ISSUE THAT CAME UP WITH THESE
RECENT WILDFIRES AYE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND I DO HAVE WITNESSES SUPPORT
KAREN LAYING.
AND FROM.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
TREASURES AND TAX COLLECTORS.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CAROLINE CAROLING ON BEHALF OF
CALPERS CESSATION OF COUNTY
TREASURERS THE TECH SECTORS
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCREPANCY
BETWEEN AYE COUNTY DEPARTMENTS
BETWEEN ASSESSORS AND HEART
ATTACKS ACTORS OVER HOW TO
HANDLE. THE CLAIMS THAT WERE
COMING IN BECAUSE THEY WERE VERY
ACROSS THE DIFFERENT COUNTIES AS
FAR AS I WHEN THEY WERE TWO AND
THEN IF IF ITWASN'T EVIDENT
REACHED AS.
THRESHOLD WHEN DO YOU HAVE TO
MAIL TO THEM TO LET THEM KNOW
THEY STILL TO PAY THEIR TAXES SO
THIS SOLVES THE LONG STANDING
PROBLEM THAT WAS BROUGHT INTO
SHARP RELIEF. AND THE FALL WITH
THE NUMBER OF HOMES THAT BURNED
IT WAS JUST A MUCH BIGGER.
APPLICATION PROCESS THAT THE
OUTRAGE TAX LATER SAW THIS YEAR
AND WE THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT WILL.
ON IN THE UNFORTUNATE
CIRCUMSTANCE IN SOMEONE'S HOME
BURNS ON TO THE FUTURE. OF THIS
BILL WILL AT LEAST MAKE THEIR
TAX PAYMENT PROCESS LESS PAINFUL
AS THEY TRY TO REBUILD MASS
PRIVATE STATE THINK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
CNN WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST TO SAY WE ARE TAKING THE
AMENDMENT SAID HAD CLARIFIED
THAT EARLIER AND YOU ASK YOUR
RIVAL.
I SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM THAT.
ACTION IS TO PASS MANDATE TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
I AM AMENDMENTS ARE JUST TO
CLARIFY PARA PAYMENT DEADLINE SO
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WE FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY FOUR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
IT'S ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO BE
BEFORE YOU AND YOUR BRILLIANT
COMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS MEASURE.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
TODAY COMMITTEE MEMBER TODAY.
AS CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE FORTY
FOUR WHICH WILL CREATE THE
SCHOOLS NOT PRISONS. VOLUNTARY
TAX CONTRIBUTION FUND.
TODAY MEN OF COLOR REMAIN OVER
REPRESENTED IN THE PRISON
POPULATION IN FACT THREE OUT OF
FOUR MALE PRISONERS ARE NON
WHITE.
IT IS NO COINCIDENCE THAT
RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS THAT
STUDENTS OF COLOR ARE EXPELLED
AND SUSPENDED AT HIGHER RATES.
THEN NONWHITE CHILDREN IN FACT
ONLY SIXTY SEVEN PERCENT OF
BLACK BOYS GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA AND IF THEY
END UP IN THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE THE STATE WILL END UP
SPENDING OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. PER YEAR TO
KEEP THAT YOU TO INCARCERATED
ONE WE ONLY INVESTED ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR. ON
THEIR EDUCATION
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA'S TO DONATE A PORTION
OF THE TAX RETURN TO PROJECTS
THAT.
THAT AND THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE THROUGH A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROCESS ADMINISTERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
THESE CONTRIBUTIONS WILL.
BOY PROVIDE.
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS AND EVENTS
USED LEADERSHIP. COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING DEVELOPMENT OF LIFE
SKILLS WORKFORCE READINESS AND
MENTORSHIP FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE. WITH ME TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE IS
MICHAEL LYNCH CO FOUNDER AND CEO
OF IMPROVE YOUR TOMORROW.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF IMPROVE
TOMORROW WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AB TWO NINE FOUR FOUR
SCHOOLS ARE PRETTY FUN AND
APPRECIATE ITS MEMBER JONES
SAWYER IS CONTINUED LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE.
ONE IS MICHELANGELO'S SIR ABOUT
THE CO FOUNDER AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF IMPROVING
TOMORROW PROVA MARS AND
NONPROFIT BASE IN SACRAMENTO
FOCUS ON BREAKING THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE FOR YOUNG MEN OF
COLOR BY HELPING THEM GET. TO
WIN THROUGH COLLEGE CURLY SERVE
MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
STUDENTS ACROSS SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND COLLEGE STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE.
I WHITEY MAKES A TWELVE YEAR
COMMITMENT TO STUDENT PROVIDE A
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT SERVICES FROM
SEVENTH GRADE UNTIL COLLEGE
GRADUATION.
YOU MEN OF COLOR CONTINUE TO BE
OVER REPRESENTED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. UNDER REPRESENT
OUR STATE'S HIGHER EDUCATION IS
A TO SINCE THE MAKE UP THE
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS PUSHED INTO
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
THESE YOUNG MEN HAVE A WIDE
VARIETY OF NEEDS THE MAJORITY OF
WHICH ARE NOT BEING MET BY
SCHOOLS THIS IS WHERE COMMITTEE
BASED NONPROFIT COMING. I HELP
TO FILL THE VOID LEFT BY SCHOOLS
AND FAMILIES BY PROVIDING
PROGRAMMING TO HELP STUDENTS
BECOME COLLEGE AND CAREER READY.
THIS WORK IS NOT CHEAP
DISMANTLING THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE WILL TAKE MONEY.
NONPROFITS ACROSS THE STATE LIKE
IMPROVING MORE WORKING WITH SOME
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE YOU TO
ENSURE THEY DO NOT BECOME
ANOTHER.
STATISTIC.
SCHOOLS NOT PRISON FUND PROVIDE
A FUNDING MECHANISM TO A GRANT
PROGRAM RUN BY THE CALIFORNIA
PART OF EDUCATION UNFUNDED TO A%
VOLUNTEER TAX CONTRIBUTION.
WHICH ALLOWED NONPROFITS TO NOT
CONTINUE THEIR WORK BUT GROW
THEIR IMPACT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUNG
ABOUT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RON RAP
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT. OF WE THINK THIS IS
A CREATIVE WAY TO SOLVE A VERY
IMPORTANT PROBLEM AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING THAT WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
YES ARM IT BEFORE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL EGGS WHICH YOU KNOW
THAT I'M.
THE PRESENTER TODAY USE STARTED
AS AN INTERN AND STATE SENATOR
CURRENT PRICES OFF.
HE WORKED IN MY OFFICE WAS
ALLEGEDLY AND NOW HELPS HUNDREDS
OF SACRAMENTO YOUNG BOYS. ON IN
THE COMMUNITY RIGHT NOW TO STAY
ON THE RIGHT TRACK AND STATIC
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE. OF WHY PUT HIS
BILL FORKS OR RESPECT LAST FOR
YOU AYE VOTE.
AND IT'S GOODTO SEE HIM BACK
HERE PRODUCING.
I WILL ONLY HAVE A QUORUM THE
RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
LIVING TO. FILE ITEM TEN AB
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REGARDING A SUNSET
FOR THE EXEMPTION AND THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS. AS IT
OFFERS AMENDMENT. WITH REGARD TO
THE COMMENT ON THE DEFINITIONS
AS MENTIONED ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS MY STOP THE COMMITTEE
CAME TO AN AGREEMENT LANGUAGE
NARROWING THESE DEFINITIONS AND
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THOSE AS
OSTROGOTHIC AMENDMENTS ALSO.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND STOP WORKING WITH MY OFFICE.
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY PROVIDES
FOR A THREE DAY SALES AND USE
TAX EXEMPTION HOLIDAY DURING THE
LAST WEEKEND OF MARCH FOR
CERTAIN QUALIFIED WATER
EFFICIENCY PRODUCTS THAT WOULD
HELP CALIFORNIANS. REDUCE THEIR
WATER USAGE BOTH INDOORS AND
OUTDOORS.
SOME PRODUCTS ELIGIBLE FOR AN
EXEMPTION OR SOAKER DRIP
IRRIGATION HOSES WHETHER BASED
IRRIGATION CONTROLLERS AS WELL
AS WATERSENSE CERTIFIED
PRODUCTS.
LIKE SHOWER HEADS LOW FLOW
TOILETS AND FAUCET AERATORS.
BASED ON INFORMATION FROM THE U.
S. EPA WATERSENSE LABELED
IRRIGATION CONTROLLER CAN SAVE
AN AVERAGE HOME NEARLY EIGHTY
EIGHT HUNDRED GALLONS OF WATER
ANNUALLY.
INSIDE THE HOME REPLACING
INEFFICIENT FAUCETS WITH AND
AERATORS WITH WATERSENSE LABEL
PRODUCTS CAN SAVE ONE HOUSEHOLD
SEVEN HUNDRED GALLONS A YEAR.
AS I'VE SPENT THE LAST YEAR
WORKING ON THE LONG TERM
EFFICIENCY BILLS I REALIZE THAT
THE STATE ALSO NEEDS TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES TO CONSUMERS IN ORDER
TO MEET OUR GOALS TO MAKE TO
MAKING CONSERVATION A WAY OF
LIFE IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M AWARE THAT THIS BILL MIGHT
HAVE AN IMPACT ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND I'M WILLING TO
TAKE LANGUAGE PROPOSED BY THE
COUNTIES TO ALSO ENSURE THAT THE
LOCAL RATE AND CHAIR OF THE
STATE. ARM PORTION REMAINS
INTACT.
THIS BILL IS BASED ON A TEXAS
LAW THAT PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO
THAT PROVIDED A MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND SALES AND USE TAX
EXEMPTION FOR THESE TYPE OF
PRODUCTS.
PROVIDING AN ANNUAL SALES AND
USE TAX A TAX EXEMPTION FOR A
THREE DAY PERIOD WILL CREATE AN
INCENTIVE FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
IMPLEMENT MORE AFFORDABLE WATER
CONSERVATION PRACTICES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. WELL ACHIEVEMENT
SIGNIFICANT WATER SAVINGS IS
ALSO A GREAT WAY FOR. THE MONEY
MANUFACTURERS OF PRODUCTS IN
STORES TO REALLY PROMOTE WATER
EFFICIENCY IN CALIFORNIA AND
CREATE EXCITEMENT AND GENERATE
BUZZ.
TO TRY TO GET PEOPLE TO PAY
ATTENTION AND BE WILLING TO MAKE
THESE CHANGES IN THEIR OWN
PROPERTIES. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
ONE SEVENTY IS MCCALL QUAN
ACCORD HONDAS ON BEHALF OF
SCOTTS MIRACLE GRO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NICKEL CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
THE SCOTTS MIRACLE GRO COMPANY.
US THE LAST MONDAY THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
REPORTED THAT THE SIERRA NEVADA
SNOWPACK WAS THAT FIFTY TWO
PERCENT OF AVERAGE SO PROOF IF
ANYONE STILL NEEDED AT THAT WE
STILL NEED TO CONCERT CONTINUE
TO CONSERVE WATER. AND USE IT
MORE EFFICIENTLY WE SUPPORT A.
B. THIRTY ONE SEVENTY BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES CALIFORNIANS WITH THE
PRACTICAL INCENTIVE TO IMPLANT
IMPLEMENT MEANINGFUL WATER
CONSERVATION.
SCOTTS MIRACLE GRO SURVEYED
RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA TWENTY
FIFTEEN AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
DROUGHT AND FOUND THAT SEVENTY
PERCENT OF RESPONDENTS WERE
WILLING TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO CONSERVE WATER.
HOWEVER ABOUT THE SAME
PERCENTAGE WEREN'T WILLING TO
REMOVE COMPLETELY REMOVED HER
FROM THEIR LANDSCAPES.
THIS BILL AIMS TO INCENTIVIZE
THOSE WHO ARE NOT FINANCIALLY
ABLE TO COMPLETELY REMODELED
THEIR LANDSCAPE OR LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO CONSERVE AND STILL
MAINTAIN WHAT WORKS BEST FOR
THEIR FAMILIES.
ALSO.
IN TERMS OF THE IRRIGATION
CONTROLLERS AND.
A LEADING TECHNOLOGY SCOTTS
MIRACLE ROTH ALSO TESTING
WHETHER BASED CONTROLLER THAT
SHOWN TO SAVE EIGHT TIMES THE
WATER OVER A TRADITIONAL
IRRIGATION CONTROLLER.
OVER THE LAST TWO MONTH PERIOD
BY ACCURATELY PREDICTING THAT
WATER LEVELS IT WITHIN SOIL AND.
BASING IT ON ARENA FANS
SO NEW TECHNOLOGIES LIKE THIS
COUPLED WITH LONG STANDING AND
PROVEN TECHNOLOGIES LIKE MALT
DRIP IRRIGATION HOSES.
.
CAN DELIVER SIGNIFICANT WATER
SAVINGS AND WE HOPE A WITH TOOLS
LIKE THIS WEEKEND FAR A.
EXCEED THE GOVERNOR'S GOAL OF
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT WATER
CONSERVATION IN THE STATE
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROSY THOMPSON
WITH METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JASON I COULD WITHOUT AUSTIN
GILBERT ROBESON SMITH. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION. ALSO IN
SUPPORT AS WE ALL CONTINUE TO
WORK TO MEET OUR STATE AND LOCAL
CONSERVATION GOALS. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE AS MANY
TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX AS
POSSIBLE.
THIS BILL IS ANOTHER REALLY GOOD
TOOL THAT WE CAN ALL USE THANK
YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JERRY DOESN'T
ON BEHALF OF PLUMBING
MANUFACTURES INTERNATIONAL WE
BELIEVE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL INSPIRE THE PURCHASE A
TOILETS FAUCETS AND SHOWERHEADS
AT MEET THE WATER SINCE LEVELS
AND SAVE ADDITIONAL WATER
CALIFORNIA.
MELISSA WARNER ON BEHALF OF THE
HOME DEPOT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DOROTHY JOHNS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE ARE LISTED I SUPPOSE
MUST AMENDED BUT. BUT THE
AUTHORS GENEROUS AMENDMENTS WILL
BE MOVING THAT OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
UP ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LIKE COMMAND
CHAIR.
THOUGHT DISAGREED BILL BE
SUPPORTED TODAY BUT I WAS
CURIOUS IF THERE WAS A REASON
WHY PAID LAST WEEK IN MARCH.
WE WERE TRYING TO FIND A WEAK
AND THAT WAS RESPECTFUL OF OTHER
HOLIDAYS WHEN IT DIDN'T.
DIMINISH SOMETHING LIKE A
VETERANS DAY OR MEMORIAL DAY
THAT'S OF THAT OUR SOLEMN
OFFENSE.
SO WE WERE SORT OF SEARCHING
FOR THE PERFECT WEEKEND WERE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO TO AMENDMENTS
AS. IDEAS I THOUGHT MAYBE THAT
WAS A PEAK RETAIL BUYING DAY OR
SOMETHING SO.
FROM THE HUNGER THE LAWN AND
GARDEN SECTOR IT'S SORT OF KICKS
OFF.
SORT ABOUT HOME IMPROVEMENT
SEASON IF YOU OFFER FOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CLOSE.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
WILL. THEN TAKE A VOTE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I AM NUMBER ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KILEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN
.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS
I'M EXCITED TO PRESENT YOU TODAY
A BILL THAT HAS FOURTEEN CO
AUTHORS. AND FOLLOWS SIX OTHER
STATES ARE RED AND BLUEMIX
OREGON MONTANA LOUISIANA ALABAMA
MISSOURI AND IOWA. IN SENSIBLY
REFORMING OUR TAX CODE.
NOW TAX REFORM IN CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A NOTORIOUSLY INTRACTABLE
ISSUE.
BUT RECENT EVENTS HAVE PRESENTED
A RARE OPPORTUNITY FOR
BIPARTISAN CONSENSUS.
AS YOU MAY RECALL LAST YEAR'S
FEDERAL TAX REFORM BILL CAPPED
THE STATE AND LOCAL TAX
DEDUCTION. COMMONLY KNOWN AS
SALT.
MANY OF OUR STATE LEADING
ELECTED OFFICIALS HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERN OVER THE IMPACT THIS
WILL HAVE ON CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS.
FOR EXAMPLE FORMER SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM KEVIN DE LEN
HAS STATED THAT HAPPENED THE
SALT DEDUCTION AMOUNTS TO QUOTE
DOUBLE TAXATION.
HE ADDED THAT THE LOSS OF THE
SALT DEDUCTION HURTS CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS AND HURTS THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
IN ADDRESSING THE LOSS OF HIS
BENEFIT FOR CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
GOVERNOR BROWN IS CALLED THE
FEDERAL LEGISLATION A
MONSTROSITY AND EVIL IN THE
EXTREME.
CONSEQUENTLY SENATOR DELEON HAS
DESCRIBED THE NEED TO QUOTE MAKE
TAXPAYERS HOLE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT IS FULLY
WITHIN OUR POWER AS THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO DO JUST THAT.
TODAY'S BILL ANSWER SENATOR W.
OWNS CALL TO MAKE TAXPAYERS HOLE
BY RESTORING IT THE FULL
BENEFIT.
OF THE SALT DEDUCTION FOR
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS.
TO RESTORE THE FULL BENEFIT OF
SALT.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR WOULD
ALLOW CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS TO
DEDUCT THEIR FULL FEDERAL TAX
LIABILITY ON THEIR STATE TAX
WHICH.
JUST LIKE SALT JUST THE OTHER
WAY AROUND.
NOW MATHEMATICALLY THIS IS THE
SAME AS SALT FOR THE TAXPAYER.
DEDUCTING FEDERAL INCOME TAXES
ON A STATE RETURN LEAVES THE
TAXPAYER IN THE SAME POSITION AS
DEDUCTING STATE INCOME TAXES.
ON A FEDERAL TAX RETURN.
WHAT CALLING IT THE NEW
DEDUCTION THE PEPPER DEDUCTION?
IT WOULDN'T SENATOR W. OWNS
WORDS MAKE TAXPAYERS HOLE AND
BENEFIT MIDDLE CLASS CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS WELL ELIMINATING ANY
CONCERNS. ABOUT DOUBLE TAXATION.
BUT THERE'S MORE.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR WILL ALSO
BRING A MUCH NEEDED DOSE OF
STABILITY.
THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET.
THE NONPARTISAN LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE HAS REPEATEDLY
SOUNDED THE ALARM ABOUT THE WILD
VOLATILITY OF STATE REVENUES
WHICH ARE AT THE MERCY OF THE
STOCK MARKET. AND ONE OFF
EVENTS.
GOVERNOR BROWN RAISE THE SAME
CONCERN IN DISCUSSING THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET SAYING CALIFORNIA
HAS A VERY VOLATILE TAX SYSTEM.
IT MEANS THAT MONEY COMES IN
VERY GENEROUSLY AND BUT WE ONLY
BUT IT GOES OUT THE SAME WAY.
MY PROPOSAL WOULD REDUCE
VOLATILITY FORTIFYING STATE
FINANCES AGAINST THE INEVITABLE
NEXT RECESSION.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
TAXPAYERS AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ACROSS THE STATE IS SHAUN
WORSE WITH THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
FROM LEWIS OF THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT
AS AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR WOULD
BRING MUCH NEEDED TAX RELIEF TO
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND
WORKING FAMILIES IN THIS VERY
HIGH TAX STATE. AS THE AUTHOR
ALREADY VERY ACCURATELY COUNTED.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT WE ARE IN
THE HIGHEST TAXED STATE IN THE
NATION WITH THE HIGHEST
CORPORATE TAX THE HIGHEST INCOME
TAXES THE HIGHEST STATE SALES
TAX AND ONE OF THE HIGHEST. GAS
TAXES IN THE NATION IT'S NO
SECRET OR NO SURPRISE THAT ARE.
BUSINESS TAX CLIMATE INDEX HOW
RINK DOES AT FORTY EIGHT OUT OF
FIFTY JUST LAST YEAR.
SO JUST LAST YEAR THOUGH.
NFIB DID STRONGLY SUPPORT
FEDERAL TAX REFORM ON THAT WE
GOT LAST YEAR AND THOUSANDS OF
OUR MEMBERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND MILLIONS OF OTHER SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE BENEFITTING.
FROM TAX REFORM A READY.
BUT PLACES LIKE CALIFORNIA HAVE
VERY HIGH STATE TAXES ARE
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE STILL
STRUGGLING. SO STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA WITH HIGH STATE
TAXES.
.
HAD A NUMBER OF OPTIONS TO
CONSIDER WHEN THE SALT DEDUCTION
WAS CAPPED AT TEN THOUSAND.
A SIMPLE SOLUTION WE WOULD LOVE
AND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SEE IS THE SYMBOL
REDUCTION OF STATE TAXES ANDWE
DO SUPPORT THOSE MEASURES AS
WELL. BUT WE KNOW THAT'S EASIER
SAID THAN DONE SO AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR PROVIDES ANOTHER VERY
GREAT OPTIONS PROVIDE THAT KIND
OF RELIEF BY ALLOWING TAXPAYERS
TO FULLY DEDUCT THEIR FEDERAL
TAX LIABILITY. ON THEIR STATE
TAXES SULTAN RIVERS TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE AND HOPE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WELL.
AND.
MATTERS BUT ALSO JOINING ME IS
DAVID WOLF WITH THAT HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID WILL FOOT
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND AS MISTER WERE SAD I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY WITH THE HAVE
FEDERAL TAX REFORM PASSING LAST
YEAR. YOU KNOW THERE IS A
CONCERN THAT THIS COULD
OBVIOUSLY NEGATIVELY IMPACT HIGH
INCOME EARNERS AND I DO THINK
THAT IS THE REASON AND THE
RATIONALE. BEHIND THIS BILL.
EN EVEN AS MR ALWAYS MENTIONED
I THINK IN A PERFECT WORLD
RATHER YOU KNOW THAN THIS BILL
OR EVEN IN ADDITION TO THIS
SPELL.
COMING UP WITH LOWER TAXES
ACROSS THE BOARD TO OFFSET
CALIFORNIA'S EXTREMELY HIGH
INCOME TAXES VERY PROGRESSIVE
INCOME TAX SCHEDULE. EIGHT
BRACKETS MEMBERS.
IN CALIFORNIA REGARDING OUR
INCOME TAX FAR AND AWAY MORE
BRACKETS THAN ANY OTHER STATE IN
THE NATION OBVIOUSLY HIGHEST
INCOME TAXES IN THE NATION.
THAT IS REALLY THE ULTIMATE WAY
TO DEAL WITH THIS PROBLEM IS
CREATE A FIGHT TAX SYSTEM CREATE
SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE EQUITABLE.
FOR TAXPAYERS ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS BILL
YOU KNOW BEGINS THE PROCESS OF
DOING THAT WERE ABSOLUTELY IN
SUPPORT OF IT THINKING.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
DARKER.
MY GOOD FRIEND.
YOU KNOW WHAT I.
LOOK AT TWENTY SEVEN BILLION IS
A LOT TO LOSE. I THINK THIS IS.
.
DEFINITELY GOING TO GO INTO
APPROPRIATIONS.
.
THE PROBLEM WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS THERE ARE XPENSES ARE VERY
HIGH WE HAVE A LOT OF KIDS AS
RESULT. EVEN THOUGH WE GIVE MORE
STATE MONEY TO SCHOOLS THEN IN
TERMS PERCENT OF THE BUDGET
FORTY PERCENT TO K. TWELVE.
ANOTHER TEN PERCENT TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
ARE WE STILL DO NOT FIND A
HIGHER EDUCATION AS WE HAVE IN
THE PAST.
AND WERE AMONG THE LOWEST IN PER
CHILD. AND SO IT YOU KNOW THAT
TWENTY SEVEN BILLION BASICALLY
HALF WOULD COME OUT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AND K. TWELVE.
I'M WONDERING IF YOU WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN AT AS PART OF THE
SPELL TO COME UP WITH THE
REPLACEMENT FOR THE MONEY WE'RE
LOSING.
WELL I I THINK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION NOW DOCTOR CLERK I WILL
JUST A BRIEF CORRECTION SO
TWENTY SEVEN BILLION THAT IS OUT
AND EIGHTEEN MONTH PER
PROJECTIONS SO I AN ANNUALIZED.
LEVEL REVENUE LOSS WOULD BE MORE
ON THE ORDER OF EIGHTEEN BILLION
AT LEAST INITIALLY WHICH MIGHT
SOUND LIKE A LOT.
BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY.
WOULD ONLY BRING US BACK ABOUT
TWO YEARS TO WHAT THE STATE
BUDGET WAS TWO YEARS AGO. AND
SO.
I THINK A PRETTY GOOD
METHODOLOGY.
FOR HOW TO DEAL WITH THAT WOULD
BE TO LET'S LOOK AT.
WHAT THE MAIN COST DRIVERS HAVE
BEEN OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
IF YOU WANT TO GO BACK TO WHEN
GOVERNOR BROWN?
FIRST TOOK OFFICE I THINK THE
BUDGET'S GONE SOMETHING LIKE
SIXTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS SINCE
THEN. AND LET'S LOOK AT TACK ON
A WHAT WE'VE GOTTEN IN RETURN
FOR THAT SPENDING OUR THEIR
MEASURABLE.
IMPROVEMENT IN LIFE OUTCOMES
FOR CALIFORNIANS AND HERDS OF
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND HEARD OF
EDUCATION OUTCOMES.
IN TERMS OF THAT AT YOU KNOW
INCOME LEVEL OR PURCHASING POWER
AND WE DON'T SEE ANY
IMMEASURABLE.
IMPROVE AND OUT COMES A LINK TO
THE INCREASE SPENDING.
THEN WE CAN REMOVE THAT
SPENDING AND I THINK TO BE VERY
EASY TO ACTUALLY I GO BACK JUST
TO AGAIN WHERE WE WERE AT. AYE
TWO YEARS AGO NOW I WILL SAY
THAT IF YOU KNOW COSTS ARE
CONCERNED HAS YOU.
ACCURATELY NOTE THIS WILL HAVE
MORE HURDLES TO GO THROUGH IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND OF
COURSE ALL THIS CAN BE
NEGOTIATED US SO I THINK YOU CAN
CONSIDER TODAY'S BELL. I SIMPLY
A VOTE TO ENDORSE THE PRINCIPLE
I THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
DEDUCTIBILITY WHICH I THINK BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE.
SEEM TO AGREE ON THAT I YOU
KNOW IF YOU BELIEVE THAT THE
SAME ARE YOUR TOTAL INCOME
SHOULDN'T BE.
ASSEMBLY.
MISTER KILEY THIS WAS IN FACT
ADOPTED ORIGINALLY TO PROTECT
STATES RIGHTS THEIR ABILITY TO.
ENGAGE IN ACTIVITIES AND I
DON'T.
JUST JUST SEEMS A CONTRARY TO
THAT I'D I'D BE CURIOUS TO HEAR
YOUR RESPONSE BATES RIGHT SINGLE
ARE
CONCERNED ACTUALLY THIS IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF FEDERALISM IS
THAT SOME STATES ARE LIKE THE
ONES I LISTED OUT WERE AGAIN
MONTANA LOUISIANA ALABAMA
MISSOURI. AND IOWA DO IN FACT
HAVE.
THE TAX POLICY THAT I'M
PROPOSING AND I AND OTHERS DON'T
AND IT'S WITHIN THE THE POWER OF
EACH STATE TO DECIDE THEIR
APPROACH AND I'M SAYING THAT WE
SHOULD JOIN THESE OTHER STATES
IN ANDTAKING THE APPROACH OF
ALLOWING. FEDERAL TAXES TO BE
DEDUCTIBLE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS WITH ME.
SEEING NO ONE JULY TO CLOSE.
OUT.
I WE WE HAVE A QUORUM WE'RE
GONNA HOLD CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
CLERK IT'S SHOULD PAT OKAY WE
HAVE A
QUORUM.
AT THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES BOTTOM ROW THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER FOUND ASTHMA MENTION
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
INCOME TAXES IN THE COUNTRY. AND
YET WE ALSO HAVE MORE OF OUR
CITIZENS LIVING IN POVERTY THE
HIGHEST COST OF LIVING IN ONE OF
THE LOWEST PERFORMING STATE
GOVERNMENTS BY JUST ABOUT ANY
METRIC.
WORST OF ALL WE SEE MORE AND
MORE OF OUR PEOPLE ACROSS ALL
INCOME LEVELS LEAVING FOR OTHER
STATES BECAUSE ADULT DOESN'T
MAKE ECONOMIC SENSE TO LIVE
HERE.
OR BECAUSE THEY JUST CAN'T
AFFORD TO.
FEDERAL TAX REFORM IS PRESENTED
CALIFORNIA WITH A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY.
AND WE SHOULDN'T WASTE IT ON THE
SAME GIMMICKS AND CAN KICKING
* IS FUELED OUR STATES
DECLINE TO THE POVERTY AND
INEQUALITY CAPITAL OF THE UNITED
STATES.
INSTEAD WE SHOULD SEIZE THIS
OPPORTUNITY WITH A BLUEPRINT FOR
FISCAL STABILITY AND ECONOMIC
GROWTH THAT WILL RENEW THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
SO AYE AND THAT THE AS CHAIR I
HAVE A NO RECOMMENDATION ON THIS
EIGHT. I UNDERSTAND YOUR NEED
FOR STABILITY I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT CREATING STABILITY THE WAY
TO START WITHOUT IS TO BUY BY
BLOWING A TWENTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR HOLE INTO OUR GENERAL
FUND. I ALSO DON'T THINK THE
CREATING STABILITY IS BY ASKING
FOR A CALIFORNIA GENERAL FUND TO
BORE THE BRUNT OF. WHAT OTHER
PROPOSALS DO NOT REQUIRE?
?
WITH THAT IN MIND I MEAN IT'S A
CUTE NAME PEPPERS ADORABLE BUT.
AS FAR AS TAX REFORM BILLS GO
AS FAR AS TAX FROM BILLS GO I
DON'T KNOW THAT YOU HAVE AN
ANALYSIS THAT SHOWS EXACTLY WHO
WOULD BE AFFECTED BY THE NEW TAX
REFORM POLICIES. IN UNTIL YOU
HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THAT I THINK
IT WOULD BE IRRESPONSIBLE TO
TAKE OF TO BITE OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND AT THE TO THE TUNE
OF TWENTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
I FULLY AGREE SAW DEDUCTION
LIMITS IT SOMETIMES WILL HAVE TO
BE ADDRESSED BUT WE SHOULD KNOW
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BEFORE
WE DO IT.
WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL SECOND. OF NO WE ONLY
HAVE A MOTION WE DON'T HAVE A
SECOND ON THIS.
BUT.
SECOND.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE.
NO BURKE NOW PEROT BRO I BONTA
CHIU.
CHIU NELL GRAY.
GRAY NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MELINDA'S. MULLIN.
QUIRK.
NO WORK NO VOEPEL AYE. VOEPEL
AYE.
THANK YOU IT'S TWO TO THREE.
WHILE I AM NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY
FOUR FOURTEEN DOCTOR CHOI WHO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIR BURGER AND THE
MEMBERS.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
OUR MIGHT BE A LAW A. B..
.
TWENTY FOUR FORTY. OUT LIKE TO
START OFF.
BY ACCEPTING THE COMEDIES
AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL LOT WOULD OFFER A TAX
INCENTIVE.
AND THE CREDIT UP TO OUR.
HOMEOWNER SO TO OFFSET.
THE PURCHASE AND THE
INSTALLATION OF OUR ADDICT BENT
CLOSE CHAU SYSTEM FOR THE OUR
HOME. IN ORDER TO PREVENT THE
FIRES.
AB TWENTY FOUR FOURTEEN WILL
HELP REDUCE FIVE YOURSELF FROM
SPREADING TO RESIDENTIAL HOMES.
DURING Y. FIRE.
IN PROVIDING A TAX CREDIT OF UP
TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE
PURCHASE AND INSTALLATION OF
WHAT AT EXPAND TO CROATIA
SYSTEM.
THIS SET ADDICT BANTER CLOSURE
SYSTEM CAN TO PREVENT THE FIRES
OF FROM SPREADING. INTO HOMES UP
BY BLOCKING FLYING. EMBERS.
SUCH A SYSTEM IS A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE. ACCORDING TO ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE OFFICIALS.
VENDORS SO WHO CAN INSTALL VISA
ADVANTA KOSHER SYSTEM I HAVE
BEEN APPROVED.
AND ARE LISTED DOT IN THE
CALIFORNIA WEBSITE.
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA HAD FACED
A NUMBER OF A FIGHTER SO.
UP CHIU UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
ARE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND ARE IN THE PAST.
SEVERAL FIRE CHIEFS.
HAVE STATED THAT THE FAMILIES
TEMPORE WAY.
TO PREVENT THE FILE YES A FROM
DESTROYING HOMES IS TO INSTALL
ATTIC FANTASIST APPROACH OF
SYSTEMS.
CURRENTLY I.
BRENT ON AMBER GUESSING INTO AN
ADVANTAGE.
THE FIRE WOULD LIKELY SPREAD
THROUGHOUT THE HOME.
THIS IS DUMB MAIN WAY.
THAT THE AYE AYE AMBER SAW ARE
GETTING INTO A HOME SITE AND
DUTCH ASSURING THEM.
AS YOU MAY KNOW ELEPHANTA SYSTEM
IS SUCKS THE AIR AND THE WIND
THE WIND THE FOR OSAKA AMBLE
FOLLOW SO THROUGH VIA. A SECOND
AIR INTO THE HOMES.
FOR ALL OUR FEEL PRIZE OF THERE
ARE SOME VENDORS SELL WHO CAN
INSTALL ADDICT.
VAN TAKRAW SHERIFF'S
OR NOT HOME SO WHICH WERE NOT
THEM IT WITH A SUCH GROTIUS.
THIS.
VENDORS I HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY
CAL FIRE AND ARE LISTED DON'T
ONE DO WEBSITE.
IN OUR EDITION. I'D BE ECHECK
SOFTSWITCHES SOUGHT ARE
INSURANCE SUBDURAL Y. INSTITUTE
FOR HOME SAFETY. RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN. THAT THE HON. ONE EIGHTH.
OF AN INCH MASHING INSTALLED THE
AROUND ATTIC FAN THE OPENING SO.
OR SO WE PROTECT OUR A HOME FROM
MEMBERS ARE ENTERING THROUGH THE
ATTIC VENTS.
PER THE FIRE CHIEFS OUT THAT
CLOUT WE HAVE MET THE WHICH.
AND I JUST SAT AT IT THEN SO
OVER NINETY FIVE PERCENT
EFFECTIVE.
AT THAT A TIPPING FIRE MEMBERS
SAW.
OUT OF THE HOME.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FACED
ON.
ONE OF THE WORST YEAR SECOND
CALIFORNIA OUT WHILE FIRE
HISTORY.
WILDFIRES ARE DESTROYED DOT WHAT
DAMAGE DONE MORE THAN TEN FALSEN
STRUCTURE SITE IN CALIFORNIA IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
THIS DESTRUCTION DUE TO FIVE
YEARS SAW IN MORE THAN NOT WHAT.
OUR STATE HAS FACED IN THE LAST
TEN YEARS COMBINED.
DID NOT FOR. AND A SOMEWHAT
COUNTY FIVE YEARS ALONE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
TOOK.
FIFTY SIX HUNDRED HOMES.
IT WAS AUTHORED AT LEAST A FIVE
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA SAY HISTORY
KIDDING.
TWENTY TWO PEOPLE.
IN ORANGE COUNTY.
BOB BYE DR DESTRUCTION WAS SOME
MUCH LESS THAN NOT IN CENTRAL
AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SO THE
ACT CANYON TOOL FIRE WHICH
DESTROYED THE TWENTY FIVE THE
STRUCTURES.
AND DAMAGE FIFTY FIVE. I
PERSONALLY TOWARD THE DAMAGE OF
THE AREA SO IN MY DISTRICT.
ACCORDING TO ACCOUNT FIVE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ONCE THE
OUT MOST IS DESTRUCTIVE AND.
DEADLY YEAR OF A FIVE YEAR FILE
YOURSELF FOR CALIFORNIA.
A TOTAL OF ABOUT NINE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY THIRTY FIVE
YEAR.
BURN DOT WHICH INCLUDED THE.
ONE MILLION THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE THOUSAND.
FOUR OR FIVE ACRES.
THIS.
INCENTIVE AND SIGH A SMART THE
INVESTMENT.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE
AND THE HOMES DOUBLE CALIFORNIA
WITH A LITTLE TAX INCENTIVE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN KEEPING OUR
STATE.
AND THE HOMES A SAFER BY
PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF FIRE
SIDE. AND AVOIDING.
I ON AB. TWENTY FOUR SEVENTH.
THANK YOU.
SECOND.
ANY WITNESS THAT UP AND SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MY CONCERN IS THIS IS A HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S A
LOT OF MONEY. AND MANY PEOPLE
CAN AFFORD THIS.
AND YOU'RE GIVING MONEY TO
EVERYBODY WHERE THEY CAN AFFORD
IT OR NOT YOU'RE GIVING MONEY TO
PEOPLE WHO WOULD DO THIS ANYWAY.
SO I JUST DON'T THINK THIS IS
THE BEST WAY TO SPEND THAT MONEY
SO I'LL BE VOTING NO BUT I
PRETTY SURE YOU CAN TO GET
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT ANYWAY.
THANK YOU. IF I MAY OUT RESPOND
TO YOU I THINK THAT THIS HAS
HAS.
INVEST MORE LEYVA INVESTING OF
ONE FORM ONE HOME ARE BURNING
ONE SIDE THAT WITH THE STRONG
WIND ARE. EASILY NEXT DOOR IS
SON LESSON FIVE FEET AWAY MY
HOME SYSTEM NEXT DOOR. AND IT
CAN EASILY FLY. INTO THE YES
SUCKING VENT.
SO ARE ENCOURAGING PEOPLE. WE
ARE NOT MANDATING WE ARE
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO INSTALL
SUCH OUT OF PRESENT NAM THE
CLOSER SYSTEM SO THAT WE CAN
SEE.
MILLIONS OF OUR PODEROSA AND THE
HOME RULES OUR LOSSES ARE IN THE
STATE.
SO OUR.
I DON ARE QUITE UNDERSTAND WHY
IF THERE'S A AND YOU INTO IT IF
THE SET AND YOU'RE GONNA. OP
PREVENT DOUBLE OUR
RECOMMENDATION.
TO REDUCE THE OF FIRE
SPREAD.-OUT BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU.
BUT I WOULD STRONGLY.
I ASKED YOU REQUEST ORATION THIS
IS ARE NOT JUST A PARTY TOWN
ISSUE THIS IS HOW. CALIFORNIA
ISSUE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING THAT WE OWE LOTION FROM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BROW AND A SECOND
HOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAIN.
SO.
SANTIAGO DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT.
NO OKAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WE'VE I'VE
WORKED.
WE. WE DID DO AN S. ISN'T
SUPPORT WITH OPPOSITION WE DID
GAG.
ALRIGHT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS REALLY QUICKLY.
THE AMENDMENTS YOU ARE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS CORRECT.
ALRIGHT WE ARE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS CORRECT YES OKAY WHEN
I REVIEWED THEM REALLY QUICKLY
THE DELAY A TAX CREDIT BY ONE
YEARS OF THAT APPLIES TO THE
TAXABLE YEAR BEGINNING ON OR
AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND BEFORE JANUARY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR.
LIMIT THE CREDIT TO FORTY
PERCENT BECAUSE THEY COSTS
INCURRED IN THE TAXABLE YEAR.
PROVIDES THE DEFINITION OF
QUALIFIED COST TO REMOVE
THE-PHRASE INCLUDED BUT ARE NOT
LIMITED TO. AT A STANDARD SEVEN
YEAR CARRY FOR PROVISION FOR
UNUSED CREDIT AMOUNTS INCLUDE
ANTI DOUBLE DIPPING LANGUAGE TO
DISALLOW ULTIPLE TAX BENEFITS
FOR THE SAME ITEM EXPENSE.
ACTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED.
YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL.
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS DUE PROCESS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
AYE AYE BURKE AYE BROUGH. THROW
AYE BONTA CHIU.
GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK NO WORK NO
VOEPEL. AYE.
THANK YOUNG CAR AND NUMBERS
.
NUMBER. FILE ITEM FIVE.
AB TWENTY FIFTY FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PRELATURE LIKED
OPEN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT TO EXTEND THE
PROCESSING TIME TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS AS NOTED THE
ANALYSIS ON OUR THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR. FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL. MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FIFTY MA BELL EXPERT I
TAX FUNDS SO BIZARRE CAN WILL
HAVE. TIMELY ACCESS SOON.
HAVING A MOTION A SECOND I'LL
LA.
SPEC PLEASURABLE AND TURNED OVER
TO THE LEFT THE EXPERTS
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I'M DIANE DEATH THREATS FROM THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD I'M HERE TO
SAY THAT WHERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
REPORTER CALVARY TEXTURES THIS
ISSUE WILSON'S.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WE.
THANK YOU SET IT DOWN.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIELLE CAN A
KEISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE SPILL.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN I WOULD LIKE BECAUSE I JUST
RECYCLE ASHER I VOTE.
YOUR YOU MADE THE STATEMENT
ABOUT THE AMENDMENT SO THEY
ACTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CULTURAL.
MISSION IS TO PASS IS A MINUTE
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE. BURKE
ARE AYE BURL AYE BRO AYE BONTA
CHIU.
GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY MELINDA'S.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
ALREADY VOEPEL.
THE.
APPLE IS OUT OF.
WE'RE GONNA FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN MR
ACOSTA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
.
WELL.
WHAT I MEAN?
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF.
THE EMPLOYMENT RATE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
IS WELL OVER EIGHTY PERCENT.
MOST EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THIS POPULATION CAME THROUGH
THE EFFORTS OF COMMUNITY BASED
NONPROFITS THAT SEEK EMPLOYMENT
AND CORDONS WITH THE CONSUMERS
INDIVIDUALIZED. PROGRAM PLAN HAS
ESTABLISHED WITH AN ASSIGNED
REGIONAL CENTER.
CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK LETTERMAN
ACT AND ENTITLES PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES TO SERVICES
INCLUDING HELP IN FINDING AND
KEEPING EMPLOYMENT.
SUPPORTED BY THE STATE PERSONS
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
RECEIVE VARIOUS SUPPORTS
INCLUDING JOB COACHING. WHILE
EMPLOYERS PAY THEIR WAGES.
IN ADDITION UNDER THE FEDERAL
LABOR STANDARDS ACT OR FLSA
PERSONS WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES MAY
BE PAID LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE.
IF THEY'RE EARNING OUR
PRODUCTIVE CAPACITY IS IMPAIRED
BY A DISABILITY MOVE THE BILL.
UNDER A FOURTEEN C. CERTIFICATE
PRODUCTIVITY MUST BE MEASURED
EVERY SIX MONTHS
WITH AND WAGES ADJUSTED USING
THE PREVAILING WAGE FOR THE JOB
IS A STANDARD. AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN WOULD CREATE AN
OFFSET OR CREDIT BETWEEN THE
MINIMUM WAGE AND WHAT THE PERSON
WE PAID USING FSL A PRODUCTIVITY
MEASUREMENTS.
THROUGH YOU BASED PROGRAMS WILL
PROVIDE SUPPORTS INCLUDING
PRODUCTIVITY MEASUREMENTS THAT
WOULD SERVE AS THE BASIS OF
DETERMINING THE AMOUNT OF CREDIT
ALLOWED FOR THE EMPLOYER AND
CONTINUE TO MEASURE THE
EMPLOYEES.
DOUG GROWTH IN JOB RELATED
TASKS.
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN
STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN.
YOU SEEM.
AB THIRTY ONE TO TWENTY SEVEN
STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN
ALLEVIATING THE HIGH RATE OF
UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND NOT OVER
BURDENING THE EMPLOYER WITHOUT
OF EXPENSES.
THIS BILL CREATES ANOTHER
EMPLOYMENT OPTION THAT DOESN'T
PLACE CONSUMERS IN THE POSITION
OF CHOOSING BETWEEN A SUB
MINIMUM WAGE JOB. OR NO JOB AT
ALL.
I HAVE CARL LONDON WITH ME TODAY
REPRESENTING THE SPONSOR THE
ALLIANCE SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I MEAN THIS ISN'T SUPPORT.
DAPHNE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
CARL LONDON HERE ON THE HEALTH
ALLIANCE SPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
WHEN I THINK A FOR SOFT MR
ACOSTA FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE.
FORWARD. AS HE SAID THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FOR PEOPLE IN
THIS POPULATION IS WELL OVER
EIGHTY PERCENT I.
I WAS THINK ABOUT THIS IN
ANOTHER CONTEXT WHICH IS IF WE
COULD THINK OF ANY OTHER.
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA THAT
HAD THAT KIND OF UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE WHAT WOULD WE DO AND.
THE FIRST THING IS PUBLIC DOMAIN
THIS BILL IN THE PROBABLY BLOW
RIGHT OFF. WE HAVE SOME KIND OF
RESPONSE.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE PASSED
A VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH CALL FOR EMPLOYMENT FIRST
POLICY FOR THIS POPULATION IN
OTHER WORDS THE VERY FIRST THING
THAT WE LOOK AT.
FOR ANYBODY IN IS POPULATION IS
A JOB IN TRYING TO HELP THEM GET
TO WORK YET WE STILL HAVE THAT
EIGHTY PERCENT. OF PLUS
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
THERE IS SOME CONTROVERSY
AROUND.
THE USE OF SUB MINIMUM WAGE FOR
THIS POPULATION.
AS THE SORT OF PHILOSOPHICAL
DIVIDE GOING ON RIGHT NOW AMONG
PEOPLE THAT SERVE THIS
POPULATION SOME BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE THAT ALL. OTHERS
HAVE SEEN VERY CORRECTLY I THINK
THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL
TO HELP SOME PEOPLE GET INTO
THE.
WORKFORCE AND AT THE SAME TIME.
GIVES EMPLOYERS.
THE VALUE THEY NEED WHEN
THEY'RE SORT OF AYE WAITING
THERE BOTTOM LINE THIS BILL KIND
OF MARY'S.
BOTH CONCEPTS VERY CAREFULLY. BY
BASICALLY SAYING THAT ALL YEAR
LONG IF AN EMPLOYER DECIDES TO
PAY A PERSON WHO WAS ELIGIBLE
FOR SUB MINIMUM WAGE.
AT LEAST MINIMUM WAGE THEY
COULD ENJOY AT THE END OF THE
YEAR A TAX CREDIT FOR PUTTING
THAT PERSON WORK. WHAT'S ALSO
INTERESTING ABOUT THE FEDERAL
LAW AND FOURTEEN SEE IS THAT.
PEOPLE EMPLOYED UNDER THE US GET
REEVALUATED EVERY SIX MONTHS
MOST OF US YOU GUYS EVER. I
GUESS IN EVERY TO YOUR REVIEW BY
YOUR VOTERS MOST PEOPLE HAVE AN
ANNUAL REVIEW WITH A LOOK AT BY
THEIR EMPLOYER WE LOOK AT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY DID A GOOD
JOB.
YOU KNOW WHAT DOT.
DESPITE RELATION GETS IN EVERY
SIX MONTHS MANDATORY REVIEW SO.
IF THEY'RE FOUND DURING THAT
TIME TO GET BETTER AT THEIR JOB.
THEN THEIR WAGE GOES UP UNDER
THE FEDERAL LAW MEETING THIS TAX
CREDIT WOULD GO DOWN.
SO WHICH IS IDEAL.
THE COUPLE THINGS WE'VE DONE
HERE WE'VE SUNSET AT THIS TO
REQUIRE THAT ONLY GOES FOR A
TIME LIMITED PERIOD.
AND THEN REQUIRES A REPORT BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE SO WE CAN SEE
HOW WELL THIS WORK. I CONTINUE
FIRSTHAND WE HAVE TALKED TO MANY
EMPLOYER GROUPS THE RESTAURANTS.
THE GROCER'S CAL CHAMBER.
ARE ALL LIKE THIS CONCEPT. IT'S
EASY FOR THEM AND THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT IN ORDER TO GET OUR
POPULATION WORKING WITH THEM BUT
THE SUPPORTS THAT MR ACOSTA
DESCRIBED.
IN ELECTORATE DRIVE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THINK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SPORT.
TRUTH ANDERSON WITH ARKIN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON VERY JUTTING FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE DUCK CREEK.
ARM.
SO MY CONCERN IS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONCE THE PROGRAM GETS
STARTED. AND ESSENTIALLY WHY
WOULDN'T A GROCER.
GIVE THE PERSON THE FULL MINIMUM
WAGE WHEN THE STATE'S PAYING A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE
DIFFERENCE.
I WOULD THINK THAT WHAT
HAPPENED.
AND YOU GET TO THAT TEN MILLION
DOLLAR DIFFERENCE.
MY CONCERN THOUGH IS THAT WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT IS.
AS WAS BROUGHT UP BY YOUR
SUPPORTER. IS THE.
EIGHTY PERCENT.
AND SO FAR AS I CAN SEE THIS
DOES NOTHING FOR THE EIGHTY
PERCENT WHO ARE EMPLOYED IT
GIVES MORE MONEY TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE THAT'S
IS NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT. BUT
I JUST DON'T THINK THIS IS THE
BEST WAY TO SPEND THE MONEY SO I
WON'T BE SUPPORTING IT.
I.
I APOLOGIZE BUT. THAT'S THAT IS
MY VIEWPOINT.
WELL I APPRECIATE THE THE THE
COMMENTARY THERE I THINK WHAT
WE'VE HEARD AND I LET MY OF THE
SPONSOR ACTUALLY RESPOND AS WELL
IF IF THAT THE CHAIRS INDULGENCE
BUT. VERY BRIEFLY OF WHAT I'VE
HEARD FROM A COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AND EMPLOYERS IS THAT.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO HIRE EITHER
A MORE OR BE ANYONE FROM THIS
COMMUNITY IF THEY CAN GET THE
PENCIL OUT AND GIVEN THE
SITUATIONS WHERE. WE HAVE
CHALLENGES.
WITH EMPLOYMENT IN THIS AREA
ARENA EIGHTY PERCENT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MAYBE THE
TWENTY PERCENT YOUR CONCERN IS A
TWENTY PERCENT GETTING MORE
MONEY.
BUT THEY'RE THERE THIS IS STILL
A RELATIVELY SMALL POPULATION SO
THE EIGHTY PERCENT SHOULD BE
ABLE TO BE VERY EASILY ADDRESSED
FROM WHAT I'M SEEING OUT IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE HAVE SEVERAL
EMPLOYERS IN AND NOW MY DISTRICT
THAT HIGHER ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY
THIS POPULATION. SO IT'S NOT SO
SO MUCH DIRECTED IN THEIR
DIRECTION IT'S MORE DIRECTED IN
THE DIRECTION OF THE RESTAURANTS
THE GROCERS THE OTHER FOLKS THAT
COULD. THAT COULD GET THESE
FOLKS SAN AND HAVE A PENCIL OUT
AND THEN BE ABLE TO GET THEM TO
A POINT WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
BE MORE PRODUCTIVE AND THEY'RE
GOING TO BE LEANING LESS ON
SOCIETY AND MORE ON THEM.
FOR THE EMPLOYER TO MAKE THAT
LEAP OF FAITH
AND NOT EVERYBODY WOULD LOVE
EVERYONE FRANKLY TO MAKE THAT
LEAP OF FAITH.
THE UNKNOWN OFTENTIMES WE FOR
THAT IN THIS BUILDING IN AND AND
ON THE FLOOR OF OUR CHAMBER.
AND THE FEAR THE UNKNOWN
SOMETIMES CAN BE A STE A
ROADBLOCK AND HINDRANCE FOR THE
EMPLOYER AND IF WE CAN TAKE AWAY
ONE MORE BARRIER TO ENTRY FOR
THIS EIGHTY PERCENT OF THIS
POPULATION. HEADING IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO IT'S GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY AND AS HE SAID AS
THE AUTHOR MENTIONED AND I'M
STEALING CENTER PROBABLY.
THAT IS AS AS THE POPULATION
ARE THE EMPLOYEES. GAINS MORE
SKILL AND IS BETTER MORE
PROFICIENT AT THEIR JOB EVERY
SIX MONTHS THEY'RE GOING TO BE.
WE A RE RE EVALUATED AND AND
HOPEFULLY AND POTENTIALLY THE
GOAL AS IS THEN TO BE MORE
PRODUCTIVE ON THE JOB. AND AND
DECREASE THE INCENTIVE BUT I I I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
SUMMER QUIRK AND NINETY IN
RESPECTFULLY HOPE THAT MAYBE MY.
MY SO THE SPONSOR HERE WILL
LEVEL CHANGE MINE BUT THAT HE
WOULD NOT ADDRESSING THAT.
WIENER.
MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY UM MISTER
GORE QUE SO. JUSTIN DEBATE THIS
A LITTLE BIT OF WE PASSED
COUPLE YEARS AGO ON THE BUDGET
THAT THING CALLED.
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT.
WITH THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
PUMPED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IN TWO OUT OF THE STATE BUDGET
INTO FINDING JOBS AS POPULATION
WHERE IN THE ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
SUBSIDIZE THE JOBS WITHOUT
MODEL.
YOU GUYS ALL AGREED IN THE
BUDGET TO ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
SUBSIDIZE IN THIS CASE WE GO OUT
TO IN THE COMMUNITY EMPLOYERS.
AND WE SAY TO THEM LOOK WE KNOW
YOU HAVE A PERSON UNDER FEDERAL
LAW YOU COULD PAY LESS THAN
MINIMUM WAGE.
BUT IF YOU AGREED TO GO AHEAD
AND AT LEAST PAY THE MINIMUM
WAGE WHICH HELPS THAT PERSON AS
A CONSUMER AND APPROACH SPADE IN
THE MARKET. AND THE ECONOMY IF
YOU'LL LEAST DO THAT. WILL HELP
YOU WITH A TAX CREDIT TO OFFSET
THE SORT OF PRODUCTIVITY LOSS
YOU'RE PROBABLY GETTING OUT OF
THAT.
AND AGAIN AS WAS SAID THE PERSON
WILL GET BETTER AT THAT JOB
WHICH MEANS THE TAX CREDIT WILL
GO DOWN GIVING WE'VE DONE HERE.
LOOK AT IT AS A PILOT PROJECT
IT'S IT'S GOTTA LIMITATION ON
TIME IT WON'T BE REAUTHORIZED
UNLESS THIS WORKS AND WILL SHOW
VERY CLEARLY THAT PEOPLE GOT
JOBS THIS WAY. BUT YOU HAVE A
MODEL THAT THEY WERE YOU HUNDRED
PERCENT SUBSIDY AS THIS ONE
SAYS.
WILL HELP THE EMPLOYERS HAVE
THEY SUBSIDIZE. A DECENT PORTION
OF IT ALL YEAR LONG BEFORE THEY
GET ANY KIND OF CREDIT.
WE THINK THAT'S IMPORTANCE WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM EMPLOYERS THE
COMMUNITY RIGHT AND THE PER ONE
OF THE PROBLEMS IS THAT NO ONE
NOW HAS AN INCENTIVE TO GIVE.
SOMEONE A MERIT RAISE BECAUSE
THE MONEY IS COMING FROM THE
STATE.
AND THERE'S JUST NO I CAN SEE NO
WAY IN WHICH YOU CAN ACTUALLY BE
HIRING MORE PEOPLE I WOULD SPEND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IF WE COULD FIND A WAY TO HIRE
MORE PEOPLE THIS TEN MILLION
DOLLARS I DON'T THINK DOES THAT.
AND I WILL REVIEW TO THE CHAREST
AYE I THINK I'VE SAID ENOUGH.
AND I QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
I'M. GOOD ME VERY TOUCHED ON IT
BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT.
THIS IS AN ENCOURAGEMENT.
IT TO HIRE THESE THE SOME FOLKS
AND ANYTHING WE CAN DO FOR THIS
POPULATION.
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
STATE BUDGET IS NOT.
SOME TRIVIAL AMOUNT ON A
FRANKLY WELL FOR ITS A LOT OF
MONEY BUT IT'S ALSO. AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE OFTEN OVERLOOKED
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND WE THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO DO
THAT'S I REQUEST SOLELY ACT ASK
YOUR I THINK YOU.
AND I LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR I
DO I UNDERSTAND ART RECORDS
CONCERNS HOWEVER IT IS
UNFORTUNATE THAT WE NEED ANY
TOOLS TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
EMPLOY. PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND SO IMMEDIATE IF THIS GETS
PEOPLE OVER THE HUMP LIKE YOU
SAID A LEAP OF FAITH WHATEVER WE
CAN DO DO THAT IS IMPORTANT AND.
AND IT'S GREAT THAT WE ALL HAVE
IDEAS ON.
OTHER WAYS TO DO THAT AS WELL
AND HOPEFULLY THEY COME THROUGH
THIS COMMITTEE WITH THAT.
ERICA'S DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THAT.
THE COLOR OF.
MOTION IS TO POUNCE TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE. BURKE
EYEBROW. ROLE AYE BONTA.
CHU GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY. MELENDEZ
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK. NOT VOTING
WORK NOT VOTING VOEPEL.
WELL I IT'S CALLED MEETS ONE
THAT GOES ON CALL ME TOMORROW
THANK YOU OKAY IF VIOLATED.
UP THE FILE ITEM SERENE AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY EIGHT DOCTOR
WEBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
IT'S OKAY.
HERE THE CHAIR.
IF THIS UNIQUE TO WHAT HE WON'T
THINK YOU AND.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE FLOORS ALL DARK.
THANK YOU I LOVE THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES.
AMENDMENTS AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE CIW ON THE STAFF
WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND OUR
SPONSORS ON THESE AMENDMENTS. WE
KNOW THE MEMBERS HAVE MADE
ACTUALLY BETTER BILL OF A STRONG
TO BUILD ONE MORE EASILY TO
IMPLEMENT. I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD EIGHT SENIOR
AND SEVERELY DISABLED HOMEOWNERS
IN LOCATING INFORMATION ON HOW
TO APPLY FOR PARCEL TO.
EXEMPTION
UNDER CURRENT THE UNDER EXISTING
LAW PARCEL TAXES ARE ASSESSED ON
INDIVIDUAL PARCELS OF PROPERTY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MAY EXEMPT
SENIORS AND SEVERELY DISABLED
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE TYPICALLY ON
FIXED INCOME. FROM PAYING PARCEL
TAXES
UNFORTUNATELY MANY SENIORS IN
SEVERELY DISABLED HOMEOWNERS ARE
UNABLE TO FIND THE INFORMATION
AND HOW TO APPLY FOR PARCEL TAX
EXEMPTION.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO CONSISTENT
OH UNIFORM PRACTICE IN PLACE
LEAVING SENIORS AND SEVERELY
DISABLED HOMEOWNERS FRUSTRATED
THAT THEY COULD NOT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE EXEMPTION THAT
IS OFFERED THEM. WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS TO ADDRESS THIS
OVERSIGHT AND AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY EIGHT REQUIRES COUNTY TAX
COLLECTOR'S TO POST ONLINE
INFORMATION ABOUT SCHOOL
DISTRICT PARCEL TAX EXEMPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO SENIOR AND DISABLED
TAXPAYERS?
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY EIGHT ALSO
REQUIRES THE WEB ADDRESS OF THE
TAX COLLECTORS HOMEPAGE TO
APPEAR ON THE PROPERTY TAX BILL
WHICH IF ASSESS LINKS TO
INFORMATION ON HOW TO APPLY. FOR
PARCEL TAX EXEMPTION.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY EIGHT ONLY
APPLIES TO COUNTIES WOULD SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT THAT BOTH IMPOSE
PARCEL TAXES AND OFFER AN
EXEMPTION FROM THOSE PARCEL
TAXES.
I'M PLEASED TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WHICH
SPECIFY THAT THE EXEMPTION
INFORMATION WILL BE PROVIDED TO
THE TAX COLLECTOR BY THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND PROVIDE A ONE YOU
DELAYED EFFECTIVE DATE TO HELP
FACILITATE COMPLIANCE.
IN SUPPORT AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA TAX. PAYERS
ASSOCIATION WITH ME HERE TODAY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY EIGHT IS KAREEM
JERSEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AYE CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS A VERY
PLEASED SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY EIGHT AND HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY HAVE BEEN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIVAL.
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CARRY LAYING UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURES AND TAX COLLECTORS NOT
IN OPPOSITION TO THE PRINCIPLE
OF THE BILL WHICH IS TO HELP
PEOPLE FIND WAYS TO. APPLY FOR
THE PARCEL TAX EXEMPTION. AYE
DESPITE WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE WE
ACTUALLY DON'T GET THE NOTICE
SAYS I TO TAKE FOLKS OFF OF THE
ON THE THE PARCEL TAX THAT'S
ACTUALLY THE AUDITOR'S
RESPONSIBILITY. NAY GET THAT
INFORMATION DIRECTLY FROM THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT WE NEVER
GET NOTICE.
DID THIS PARCEL TAX EXEMPTIONS
AND HAVE BEEN INCLUDED AS PART
OF THE BALLOT. INITIATIVE SO AND
THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOUR
CONSULTANT HELP PUT TOGETHER
REALLY FIX THE PROBLEM THIS FAR
IS NOTICING IT TELLS.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT THEY NEED
TO SERVICE WITH THAT INFORMATION
IN ORDER TO PUT ON THE WEBSITE
THAT'S A REALLY CRITICAL LINK
FOR US OTHERWISE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY. AYE INFORMATION THE OTHER
THING WE WOULD OBSERVE IS THAT
THE TAX ROLLS CLOSE OUT ON JULY
ONE. AND SO WILL BE VERY HELPFUL
FOR THE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO MAKE
SURE THAT TAXPAYERS UNDERSTAND%
THAT IF THEY DON'T HAVE THEIR
APPLICATIONS SUBMITTED TIMELY.
EVEN THOUGH THE TAX BILL COMES
OUT IN OCTOBER IN ISN'T DUE
UNTIL DECEMBER FOLKS THAT SEND
IT IN AN AUGUST MIGHT NOT BE
VERY HAPPY TO FIND OUT THAT THEY
ARE NOT EXEMPT FOR THAT YEAR AND
THERE'S NOTHING REQUIRING US TO.
I DO A CORRECTED TAX BILL SO
THERE ARE STILL MORE WORK TO BE
DONE WE SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE COMMITTEE
PUT HEARTACHE MAKE THE BILL
FARMER WORKABLE. MILK FOR TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
THINKING.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMING OF.
WITHOUT OPPOSITION IT WASN'T IT
WAS LIKE IN BETWEEN.
THIS IS AN OPPOSITION.
WE.
WE WERE OPPOSED THE BILL IN
PRINT ONCE YOU SEE THE BILL AND
AND ITS NEW FORM. PROBABLY
CHANGE OUR POSITION TO AT LEAST
A NEW TOWER HOPING TO GET TO
SUPPORT ON WITH WITH A FEW MORE
TWEAKS.
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS ON THE
COMMITTEE.
SCENE I WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
YES WE WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THE BILL WE THINK AS SOME
POINTED OUT THAT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THIS COMMITTEE MADE WITH
BREAD MADE IT A BETTER BILL SO
THAT THE. SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
DOING THE NOTIFICATION AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT.
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT OF
THOSE WHO ARE DISABLED WE KNOW
AND TO THE ELDERLY TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS.
AND FIND THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED US AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
APPROPRIATIONS CRIPPLE COLOR.
MUCH AS YOU PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE. BURKE ARE
AYE BROUGH. ROLE AYE BONTA.
CHU GRAY.
GRAY I AM MCCARTY.
MELINDA S.
MELINDA'S AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
VOEPEL.
THE BILL I.
THE BILL IS OUT. AND SHE.
WHISPERED AS ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
THIS BILL.
OUR LAST BILL BE BY MADAM CHAIR.
ITEM FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT AM CHAIR WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THINK THEY CAN
THANK YOU TO THE COLONEL FOR
YOUR HARD WORK.
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
FUNDAMENTAL CALIFORNIANS
CONTINUED ECONOMIC SICK ROOM AT
BILL SECULAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
IT'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SO.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS OSCAR GONZALEZ WHO
JUST WANT TO SAY THANKS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO OPERATE.
A STATEMENT OF TESTIMONY ON
BEHALF OF THE CEO OF INSYNC THE
COMPANY THAT I WORK FOR.
IS SEAT IS A LEADING STARTUP
COMPANY FOUNDED IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE BY JAMES GUTIERREZ A
SOCIAL ENTREPRENEUR WHO IS
COMMITTED. TO HELPING UNDER
BANKED AND UNBANKED BORROWERS BE
PART OF FINANCIAL MAINSTREAM.
HIS SINK OPERATES OVER SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY STORES IN
FOUR STATES ARIZONA CALIFORNIA
ILLINOIS IN TEXAS.
IT SEEK IS ARE REGULATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT BBO AND THE
CALIFORNIA PILOT PROGRAM FOR
INCREASE ACCESS TO RESPONSIBLE
SMALL DOLLAR LOANS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA.
FINANCE LENDERS LAW.
A KEY FEATURES OF INSYNC LANDING
PLATFORM ARE ONE LOANS OFFERED
BETWEEN THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
AND TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
TOO A FLEXIBLE INSTALLMENT PAY
A PAYMENT PLAN.
THREE CREDIT BUILDING
OPPORTUNITIES IN FOR LOANS CAP
AT THIRTY SIX PERCENT.
JAMES ASKED ME TO BE HERE.
THIS AFTERNOON BECAUSE HE'S
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
HE HAS EXPERIENCE AS A FOUNDER
OF FOUR DIFFERENT COMPANIES HE'S
REYES A FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
I AN EASEL CAPITAL WHICH IS THAT
THE BASISOF THIS LEGISLATION
AND HE'S REYES APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
VENTURE CAPITAL.
IN ADDITION TO SERVING AS A C.
E. O. HE'S ALSO AN ANGEL
INVESTOR WITH INVESTMENT
ACTIVITY IN TWENTY PLUS COME
COMPANIES.
I HE'S ALSO THE OTHER VICE CHAIR
OF THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP WHICH IS THE THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY.
OF OUR COMPANY STRONG OF A TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF THE SILICON
VALLEY.
A JAMES BELIEVE US THIS ASSEMBLY
BILL IS NEEDED IN ORDER TO
STIMULATE MORE START UP CAPITAL
ESPECIALLY AMONG DIVERSE TEAMS
IN FOUNDERS WERE COMMITTED TO
INNOVATION AND JOB CREATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVEN FIVE
EIGHT OFFERS A STRAIGHT FORWARD
MEASURE BY DIRECTLY
INCENTIVIZING INVESTORS.
TO INVEST IN UNDER REPRESENTED
SMALL BUSINESSES.
OF THAT THAT MAY HAVE OTHERWISE
BEEN OVERLOOKED.
TARGETING SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
A DIFFICULT THE SECURING OF
FINANCING NOT ONLY EXPANDS.
THEIR ACCESS TO CAPITAL BUT IT
ALSO WILL IMPROVE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS NETWORK OF CONTACTS AND
PROVIDES THEM WITH EXPERIENCE.
LEADERS TO HELP GUIDE THEIR
EXPANSION.
FURTHERMORE THIS BILL A BALANCE
IS FLEXIBILITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY BY PROVIDING
INVESTORS THE PROPER INCENTIVE
AND SUFFICIENT LEEWAY TO INVEST
IN BUSINESSES THAT HAVE. THE
MOST TO GAIN FROM A GREATER
ACCESS TO CAPITAL.
IN CLOSING IT'S CLEAR THAT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVEN FIVE
EIGHT WAS WRITTEN WITH THE
UNDERSERVED.
COMMUNITIES IN MIND BOTH RURAL
AND URBAN.
JAMES BELIEVES THIS LEGISLATION
TAKES A STEP FORWARD TO ENSURE A
FUTURE WHEN SMALL BUSINESSES AND
INVESTORS WORK TOGETHER. TOWARD
A WEALTH BUILDING IN COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE COMMEND THE JUDGMENT OF EACH
OF YOU FOR TAKING LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANKS VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. CHRIS
ROSE ON BEHALF THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP THE
CREDIT WILL ENCOURAGE FURTHER
INVESTMENTS IN START UP
COMPANIES INNOVATIVE PRODUCTS.
THESE SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDE
IN THE NEW JOBS AT THEY CREATE
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
JUDICIAL IN THOSE.
SHARON QUIRK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FACTS.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
SPORT SEEN ON A DISH TOWEL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NON QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
ON THE COMMITTEE THIS QUIRK.
TRIAL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
MY CONCERN IS YOUR CALLING
THESE ANGEL INVESTORS THERE'S
ONE OTHER PART OF AN ANGEL
INVESTOR AND I DON'T THINK IS
DISCUSSED.
WHEN THE BELL LOW MAYBE I'VE
MISSED SOMETHING WHICH IS.
GENERALLY SPEAKING IT IS THOUGHT
THAT ANGEL INVESTORS ARE TAKING
ANY KIND OF MONEY OUT OF THE
COMPANY. AND WHAT THEY HAVE TO
PAY THEM IS THE EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLAR MINIMUM AND I ACTUALLY
HAD THE BILL. WHICH.
.
I BASICALLY COULDN'T GET A GOOD
DEFINITION FOR SO IT WAS.
JOINTLY WITH THE ALLEN WHICH
WOULD HAVE SAID FOR AN ANGEL
INVESTOR YOU DON'T HAVE TO PAY
THAT EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS.
SO ANYWAY MY CONCERN HERE IS
PERHAPS YOU WANT TO CHANGE IT
FROM ANGEL INVESTOR TO SOMETHING
ELSE BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE. COULD
IF I'M UNLESS I'M READING THE
BILL WRONG WHICH I MIGHT BE.
THESE PEOPLE COULD BE MAKING A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF MONEY FROM
THEIR INVESTMENT.
AND.
AND I THINK THAT OUR HOPE IS
THAT THEY'RE MAKING A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF MONEY I IN
IN THEIR INVESTMENT AT SOME
POINT I THINK OUR REAL CONCERN
HERE IS THAT AND WE WILL. CHECK
AND SEE IF ANGEL INVESTOR IS THE
PROPER TERM TO BE USED HOWEVER I
BELIEVE IT IS.
BUT.
AS ARE REPORT SHOW AS THAT.
MY NAM OUR OWN BUSINESSES ARE
GETTING TWENTY THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED HOURS COMPARED TO
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES ARE
GETTING NINETY THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FROM SECURE CAPITAL. AND
SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY JUST TRYING
TO DO HERE IS MAKE SWORE THAT
UNDERREPRESENTED. AND SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE PRIORITIZED AND
SECURE FINANCING AND SO IF ANGEL
MASTER IS NOT THE CORRECT TERM I
WILL MAKE SURE WE FIND THE
CORRECT TERM BUT I BELIEVE IT
IS.
TO SHOW MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK.
SEEING NONE OF THERE WAS A
MOTION BY MISTER VOEPEL SECOND
BY. MISTER GRAY MADAM CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECT LOW ACTUALLY YEAH CAO
PRE RECEIVES FIFTY THREE.
PERCENT OF THE NATIONAL BEST A
VENTURE CAPITAL FUNDS ONLY FIVE
PERCENT GOOD FEMALE OWNED
BUSINESSES AND A COMBINED OF ONE
PERCENT GOOD AFRICAN AMERICAN
OWNED BUSINESSES AND HISPANIC
BUSINESSES.
AB TO SET TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
PROVIDES A SIMPLE FIVE PERCENT
TAX CREDIT INVESTORS ON THE
MOUND VESTED IN SMALL BUSINESS
AND PRIORITIZING THESE
BUSINESSES WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ENABLE.
AND YOU MENTIONED.
THE AMENDMENTS AND LET ME READ
THOSE FOR CLARIFICATION NUMBER
ONE APPLIES THE REQUIREMENTS OF
PERMITTED AND OF THE INVESTOR
OR.
ANGEL INVESTOR AND DELETE
PERMITTED AND EIGHTY INVESTOR
TERM TO PROVIDES A QUALIFIED
SMALL BUSINESS MUST BE OWNED AND
CONTROLLED BY SOCIAL AND
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
INDIVIDUALS. AS PROVIDED FOR
UNDER THE SMALL BUSINESS
DURATION EIGHT A CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM AND THIRD FINALLY
REQUIRES ANGEL INVESTOR MAKE
AVAILABLE TO RETURN ON
INVESTMENTS IN A QUALIFIED SMALL
BUSINESS. TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF REVENUE AND
TAXATION CODE SECTION FORTY ONE
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION ISSUE PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE
BURKE AYE A BURL. BRO I BONTA.
CHU GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
MELINDA'S AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE VOEPEL.
IT'S.
HERE BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO THINK
YOU.
ALL HER LIFE.
SECOND.
ANYTHING INLAND.
LAKE.
STARTING WITH FILE ITEM ONE A.
B..
WELL IF THE CALL ON FILE ITEM NO
NUMBER ONE AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FOUR.
KIRK I DON'T KNOW MS HYLAND
CALLED ABSENTEES.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE.
MCCARTY.
WILL INDUCE RELIGIOUS I.
MULLIN.
MULLIN NO.
OKAY.
THEY SAID.
RIGHT WEST.
BONTA AYE.
TO KNOW.
THIRTY FIVE.
SCANS WE CAN REPLACE THE CALL.
WE CAN PLACE OUT OF THE LEADING.
OUT THE ONLY.
WE'RE WAITING FOR.
WE CAN PLACE THAT FELL BACK ON
CALL.
FILE ITEM TO AB TWENTY FOUR
FOURTEEN.
CALL THE ABSENTEE. BONTA. BONTA
I CHIU. MCCARTY.
MELINDA'S
WONDER IF AYE QUIRK OF SKINNY I
SEE MISTER QUIRK.
AB BILL IS. THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY FOUR.
SO SORRY WITH A FILE ITEM EIGHT
SOCKET
WE'LL DESIGNATE FILE ITEM EIGHT
A. B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN IS
ON CALL WITH THE CALL.
CALL THE ABSENTEES.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE.
CHIU.
MCCARTY.
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S I.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
NOW.
FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY FOUR WE DID THAT AS A SUB
COMMITTEE I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
PROMOTIONAL INTENDS.
BROUGH.
ALL THE WORLD.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE
BURKE AYE BROUGH. ROLE AYE
BONTA.
BONTA RHS YOU. GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY MELENDEZ
RELIGIOUS AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK. QUIRK AYE
VOEPEL.
BILL IS. EIGHT ZERO.
THE BILL IS OUT EIGHT ZERO FILE
ITEM SEVEN E. B. THIRTY ONE
TWENTY TWO WE NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WAS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
AYE FOR OUR I'VE RURAL. ROLE I
BONTA. BONTA AYE CHU GRAY.
GRAY I MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK I'VE ACCOUNT.
VOEPEL.
BILLS HAVE EIGHT ZERO.
NO WE STILL. FILE ITEM NINE AB
THIRTY ONE FIFTY TWO WE DO THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE IN A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
BURKE I BURKE I'VE WORLD. BRILL
AYE BONTA. BONTA HIGH CHU GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY MELENDEZ
RELIGIOUS AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK. QUIRK AYE
VOEPEL.
THE BILL I EIGHT ZERO ITSELF.
EIGHT ZERO THEM PHYLLIS OUT FILE
I AM TEN AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY.
I NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WE GOT LINDA'S WOULD THINK.
YOU ARE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WAS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
AYE BURKE ARBROATH. BRO I BONTA.
BONTA RHS YOU GRAY. GRAY AYE
MCCARTY MELINDA'S LINDAS ARE AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING VOEPEL. FELL I.
THAT TO LIFT OUR SERVER WE ONLY
HE LIFTED A CALL FILE ITEM ONE
A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR THE
FILE